known as the father of modern fantasy as
epic tales of Legend and lore been
enjoyed by millions of people all over
the world devoured in popular books and
adapted for Hollywood blockbuster films
unbelievably bright he was a
distinguished University professor poet
historian and expert linguist as a child
he even made up his own languages for
pure fun he gave us complex and fanciful
creatures including hobbits orcs and
elves set in a prehistoric middle-earth
some theorized that his made-up worlds
are symbolic of his country's past power
struggles influenced by his devout Roman
Catholic faith or simply the genesis of
his personal experiences in any case
there is no denying his glorious
imagination and his rightful place
amongst the greatest writers of all time
but who was the creator of The Hobbit in
The Lord of the Rings well today on
biographic Sui explore the life of j.r.r
tolkien
[Music]
before bank clerk Arthur Tolkien and
Mabel Suffield welcomed their son into
the world the English couple moved to
South Africa here our Arthur had high
hopes of advancing his career and
providing a comfortable life for their
budding family John Ronald Reuel known
as Ronald - most was born in BOM
Fontaine South Africa on January the 3rd
not long after another son Hilary was
born completing the talk Ian's family
talking's childhood in Africa was cut
short when his mother decided the boys
would be better educated in their native
England at the age of three Tolkien and
his mother and younger brother left for
their homeland while Arthur stayed
behind to settle the business he was
planning to join them thus never made us
falling ill and dying of a severe brain
hemorrhage a complication of rheumatic
fever on February the 15th 1896 at the
time the spread of disease and
contagions were feared and travel took
many weeks if not months Arthur's body
was laid to rest without his family by
his side having spent just a small
fraction of his early years in Africa
talking had very few memories from that
time however one tale persists but the
facts remain uncertain according to this
story the then toddler Tolkien's
stumbled upon and was bit by a baboon
spider type of tarantula in the garden
Tolkien ran screaming and his nurse
immediately snatched him up and sucked
the venom out from the wound talking
later said he could remember a hot day
and running in fear through long dead
grass but the memory of the tarantula
itself faded and he said that the
incidents left him with no especial
dislike of spiders still fans and
armchair psychologists alike speculate
whether the tarantula influenced the
presence of man-eating spiders in tokens
later fictional wax
well back in England Mabel in the boys
settled with family in the West Midlands
first in King's Heath and then in ser
Hall on one hand and especially in the
city of Birmingham the West Midlands was
urban dark and industrial on the other
hand it was the idyllic English
countryside with lush green grass trees
and a corn mill in the rural hamlet of
ser hall between the ages of four and
eight talking lived across the street
and within 300 yards of the ser hole
mill and Mosley bog he spends many hours
there playing with his younger brother
and being chased by the Millers son whom
the boys nicknamed the
oh yeah the Shire tokens imaginary land
of hobbits was inspired by Ser Hall in
The Hobbit he writes of Bilbo Baggins
running as fast as his fairy feet could
carry him down the lane past the great
mill across the water and then on for a
mile or more tokens mother homeschooled
the boys at first teaching the untold
combatant Ian's the basics of Latin
Tolkien could read fluently by the age
of four and write soon after he loved
drawing landscapes and trees but his
favorite studies were those involving
languages later he would attend King
Edward's school in Birmingham which
proved to be the perfect breeding ground
for the boys natural curiosity and
development of linguistics Tolkien was
an exceptional student he was capable of
easily mastering ancient and modern
languages including Greek Latin Spanish
Old English Old Norse gothic and Finnish
the boy made up his own languages
including early variations of elvish
ones featured in his writings at King
Edward's he made a number of close
friends and formed a semi secret society
that enjoyed drinking tea and critiquing
each other's literary works
they called themselves tcbs which stood
for the tea club and Baratheon society
despite the earlier loss of his father
life of the young tokine was generally
happy and told to events altered the
course of his life in 1900 his mother
decided to convert to the Catholic faith
this bold move left Mabel and her son's
estranged from both sides of the family
and in the fallout Tolkien experienced
isolation loneliness and poverty
following his acceptance into the
Catholic Church tokine remained devout
in his faith for the rest of his life he
has also been credited with being partly
responsible for bringing another famous
writer and friend CS Lewis fact
Christianity tragedy then struck talking
again in 1904 when his mother was
diagnosed with diabetes a sure death
sentence in that time sadly Mabel died
in the same year on November the 14th
tokine
was 12 at the time fortunately for
Tolkien and his brother Hilary their
Catholic priest Father Francis Morgan
stepped in and became their Guardian and
made sure the boys received everything
they needed both materially and
spiritually
talking messes eventual bride Edith
brass when he was 16 she was 19
they were both orphans and lodgers at a
boarding house run by a woman named mrs.
Faulkner the two group fond of each
other and a friendship developed and
then as it happens with teenagers the
pair became too close for father
Francis's liking he was horrified his
ward was courting a Protestant woman and
believed the relationship was a
distraction from Tolkien's schoolwork
father Francis forbade talking to see or
correspond with Edith until he was 21
this was a devastating blow to talking
but he obeyed the order when his
birthday approached he wrote to his love
and proposed marriage her reply was
heartbreaking but offered a glimmer of
hope she was engaged to another man but
his letter made her reconsider Edith
agreed to meet stalking on January the
8th 1913 at the train station in
Cheltenham they walked and talked for
hours and Edith accepted tokens marriage
proposal breaking off her prior
engagements Edith converted to
Catholicism and the couple married on
March the 22nd 1916 so keen was 24 years
old and a few months shy of deploying to
the Western Front in a letter to his son
Michael years later talking expressed
admiration for his wife's willingness to
marry a man with no job little money and
no prospects except the likelihood of
being killed in the great war talking
was a true romantic and Edith was his
muse he wrote of her her hair was raven
a skin clear her eyes brighter than you
have seen them and she could sing and
dance talking was so mad for Edith he
created the fictional pair of
star-crossed lovers based on their
romance lthien daughter of the elven
king of doriath and baron a mortal man
they fall for each other when baron
discovers lthien singing and dancing in
a glade yet their love can never be
since baron is destined to die alas
disapproving father the king sends Baron
on a task he knows the man cannot
complete the full story of lethean and
baron was left unfinished during
tokine's lifetime but served an
important back story in The Hobbit
Tolkien son Christopher later published
lthien and Baron as a chapter in the
saga The Silmarillion
Edith and tokine enjoyed a long and
happy marriage to each other and they
had four children John Francis Michael
Hilary Christopher John and Priscilla
Mary Anne
tokine was a devoted father
loved his children often making up
fanciful stories for them from 1920 to
1942 at Christmas time talking
Illustrated letters to his children
introducing new characters such as the
north polar bear snowman and others
three years after his death these
intimate stories were published as
letters from father Christmas by the
Tolkien estate
believing he was in his own words a
young man with too much imagination and
little physical courage Tolkien did not
rush to join the British military when
war broke out
instead he returned to Oxford where he
had achieved a first-class degree in
June of 1915 talking was busy working on
poems and his invented languages at this
time eventually though talking enlisted
as a second leftenant in the Lancashire
Fusiliers and was sent to active duty on
the Western Front just in time for the
Battle of the Somme also known as the
sole offensive the Battle of the Somme
remains one of the bloodiest military
battles in history it lasted four long
months and on the first day alone
British troops suffered over 57,000
casualties in total over a million men
lost their lives including four hundred
and twenty thousand British soldiers
fighting in the Great War talking
witnessed the horrors of trench fighting
and lived in deplorable and sanitary
conditions it was hell on earth for
Tolkien and his comrades who stood by as
their friends suffered and died
alongside them they spent their days and
nights with little relief and endured
infestations of lice that feasted on
their flesh as a result talking came
down with trench fever a major medical
problem of World War one so severe with
a lice of Chaplin staying with tokens
units later of course we dashed down for
the night in the hopes of getting some
sleep but it was not to be we no sooner
lay down than hordes of lice got up so
we went round to the medical officer who
was also in the dugout with his
equipment and he gave us an ointment
which he assured us would keep the
little brutes away we anointed ourselves
all over with the stuff and to gain lay
down in great hope but it was not to be
because instead of discouraging them it
seemed to acts like a kind of order
Irv and the little beggars went at their
feast with renewed vigour sickens unable
to fight talking left the battle front
to recover in a Birmingham Hospital in
November of nineteen sixteen through
1917 and 1918 Tolkien had bouts of the
illness and he spent time in remission
doing service at home and at various
camps talking most likely escaped death
on the Battlefront precisely because he
became ill sadly all but one of his
close friends including those from the
TCPS perished in the war as a writer
this tragedy of loss and first-hand
experience in battle provided Tolkien
with the Keynes
awareness from the unpublished the book
of lost tales talking rights in huts
full of blasphemy and smut or by
candlelight in bail tents even some down
in dugouts under shellfire
in the hobbits the Battle of the five
armies is thought to draw upon tokens
wartime experiences as well as the Dead
Marshes and Black Gate of Mordor in the
Lord of the Rings
on November the 11th 1918 the Armistice
was signed which marked the end of world
war one Tolkien was appointed assistant
lexicographer on the new english
dictionary also known as the oxford
english dictionary in 1918 but stayed on
the job ferny a short while in the
summer of 1920 he accepted a post as a
reader with the University of Leeds at
Leeds he taught and collaborated with
other authors continued writing the book
of lost tales constructed languages and
founded reading in social clubs like the
Viking Club this was an undergraduate
Club for students who had an affinity
for Old Norse Sagas and drinking yeah
in 1925 talking finally received his
professorship at Oxford the Rawlinson
and Bosworth professorship of
anglo-saxon Tolkien was right at home in
academia and fit in remarkably well with
the predominantly male culture he
reveled in the lectures research and
exchange of ideas with students and
fellow professors talking did not
publish many scholarly articles yet he
was extremely influential one lecture
worth mentioning altered the modern
study of the Old English epic tale
Beowulf and was first delivered in 1936
in bear wolf the monsters and the
critics Tolkien argued the monsters
Grendel Grendel's mother and the dragon
are not merely extraneous to the
narrative but should be a focus of study
Tolkien believed critics but too much
emphasis on the historical elements of
the tale instead of looking at it as a
work of art at Oxford toking befriended
colleagues CS Lewis best known for his
fantasy series The Chronicles of Narnia
the two men bonded over their shared
love of mythology and began meeting
regularly for a glass a joke and to
criticize each other's poetry the
meetings were so enjoyable and useful
they invited others to join the informal
group known as the Inklings eventually
grew to 19 members and they met once a
week late at night sometimes not
wrapping up until 2 or 3 o'clock in the
morning as was the practice
Tolkien shared manuscripts
works in progress with the Inklings and
received energetic feedback from the
group among other writings talking
brought original poetry sections from
The Hobbit excerpts from the notion Club
papers and each new chapter of The Lord
of the Rings there is little evidence to
support the suggestion by some that the
men had a more spiritual purpose to
their meetings the Inklings continued to
meet regularly for 19 years together
with talking and Lewis some of the more
distinguished members of the influence
included Neville cockle Hugo Dyson Owen
Barfield and Charles Williams in 1945
tokine changed his chair at oxford to
the Merton professorship of English
language & literature he held this
position until his retirement in 1959
one hot summer day in 1928 professor
talking was grading exam papers which he
described as soul-destroying he came
upon a blank page and without thought
wrote down in a hole in the ground there
lived a hobbit but what was a hobbit and
why did it live in the ground
well talking he needed to find the
answers to these questions he said later
names always generate a story in my mind
I thought I'd better find out what
hobbits were like then in true Tolkien
fashion he dove headlong into the
creative process and concocted a tale to
tell his younger children and share
amongst the Inklings in 1936 an ink
oblique copy of The Hobbit wound up in
Susan Dagmar's hands an employee of the
publishing firm George Allen & Unwin
recognizing the story's potential
d'agneau convinced me talking to finish
it and when complete she presented it to
her boss he then tested it out on his
ten-year-old son who gave it a raving
review The Hobbit was published one year
later in 1937 and was an immediate hit
in fact it was so successful that the
publisher asked tokine if he had any
similar stories today since the first
publication The Hobbit has sold more
than 100 million copies around the world
and has been translated in over 50
languages so you might be wondering well
what makes the Hobbit so enduring for
one thing it lacks female characters and
it is not nor has it ever been
politically correct it is also a very
long tale with poetry and unlike other
children's fiction
does not have a central child figure for
whom young readers
easily identify with although the
protagonist bilbo baggins is only a
little hobbit so he does kind of act
like a surrogate child talking's
colorful descriptions of middle-earth
and its complex characters goblins elves
orcs wizards dragons and hobbits of
course are richly portrayed and for all
the fantasy writers who came after
talking hardly any can say their worlds
were not at least in part influenced by
The Hobbit but what set the story apart
is the depth of emotion and moral
courage coking weaves into his heroic
fiction there are examples of this
throughout the Hobbit including the
death of dwarf leader Thorin Oakenshield
there's also build those internal
struggle to do what's right betraying
his friends while they try to reclaim
the Lonely Mountain from Smaug the
dragon
Bilbo feels an obsessive greed has
overtaken Thorin and when bull defines
the Arkenstone the greatest treasure of
all he decides to first hide it and then
give it to his friends for seizures to
be used as a bargaining chip in the end
Bilbo exposes himself and confessors
because after all they are friends after
Tolkien's publication of The Hobbit he
presented portions of The Silmarillion
including incomplete stories of lthien
and Baron to Stanley Unwin hoping for a
warm reception but his reader felt these
stories were not commercially
publishable they simply contains too
much poetry talking was disappointed to
the news but soon found himself busy
writing the sequel to The Hobbit
Tolkien's opus what would become the
Lord of the Rings this was first
published in three parts the Fellowship
of the Ring the two towers and The
Return of the King between 1954 and 1955
it took him over a decade to write these
books
Unwin son who was by now an adult was
heavily involved in pushing a
temperamental tokine to finish the books
thinking it would be a relatively
unimpressive release and a loss to the
firm the publishers grossly
underestimated the Lord of the Rings
public appeal true is had mixed reviews
from damning to glowing and everything
in between
the BBC adapted it into 12 condensed
episodes elevating its popularity
further then in the mid 1960s a pirated
paperback version was released which
caught the attention of American readers
a sort of cults then developed based on
the newfound popularity of fantasy
literature and talking was made a rich
man he was not entirely happy though
even if he was flattered partly because
rumours circulators
of party going cult readers ingesting
LSD and reading the Lord of the Rings
and indeed some overzealous fans who
talking referred to as lunatics were
calling his home and demanding to know
if radio has succeeded in his quest The
Hobbit and The Lord of the Rings
certainly receive all the glory but
talking authored a number of other
articles and essays during his lifetime
including the monsters and the critics
and other essays one middle-earth
related work The Adventures of Tom
Bombadil editions and translations of
Middle English works such as the
anchoring with Sergey win and Sir Orfeo
and the pearl and stories the in Room
the homecoming of Ben Rathbun Roth Sun
and stories the in room the lay of out
row and it Ron farmer Giles of ham leaf
by niggle and Smith of Witten major
following his death the letters from
father Christmas were released by the
token estate and later son Christopher
saw to it that his father Silmarillion
and a number of other incomplete
writings under the title of unfinished
tales of nmenor Nan's middle-earth were
published after his retirement from
Oxford Hokkien moved to Bournemouth and
on November the 29th 1971 the love of
his life
Edith died nearly two years later on
September the 2nd 1973 talking followed
as a final testament to their love and
at tokine's instruction they were buried
in a single grave on their tombstone
baron is engraved under his name and
lthien appears under Edith's
tolkien shall remain a celebrated
literary figure through the ages as his
lifework continues to inspire the
fantasy genre around the world his
characters and places have become the
namesake of various street names
companies mountains plants and objects
there are even asteroids named after
Bilbo Baggins and Tolkien himself in
England there are seven blue plaques
that commemorates places associated with
talking Tolkien was made a commander of
the British Empire by Queen Elizabeth in
1972 and he holds a number of other
achievements and awards including an
honorary degree from the National
University of Ireland and the University
of lige in 1954 and the Lucas award for
the best fantasy novel for The
Silmarillion in 1978 in the 2000s toking
ranked on BBC's greatest Britons list
and the Lord of the Rings was the UK's
best love novel in 2003 and ranks among
the hundred greatest British novels in
2015 dokyun was placed sixth on the list
of the 50 greatest British writers since
1945 published by The Times in 2008 in
2009 he was listed as the fifth top
earning dead celebrity by Forbes from
2001 to 2003 New Line Cinema released
the Lord of the Rings as a trilogy
directed by Peter Jackson the series was
extremely successful and won numerous
Oscars from 2012 to 2014 Warner Brothers
and New Line Cinema released The Hobbit
a series of three films based on The
Hobbit book the first in 2012 The Hobbit
an unexpected journey the second in 2013
the hobbit the desolation of Smaug and
the final instalment in 2014 The Hobbit
the Battle of the five armies talking's
middle-earth is surely the gift that
keeps on giving and it is quite amazing
considering he wrote it all in his spare
time so I really hope you enjoyed that
episode of biographic if you did there's
a couple of things you could do right
now one is hit that like button below
also if you want more stuff like this we
put out brand new videos every Monday
and every Thursday so hit that subscribe
button below and subscribe button
doesn't do what it used to on YouTube if
you actually want to get a notification
about these videos please do hit that
Bell button next to the subscribe button
and that'll send you a notification
every time every Monday and Thursday
won't put out a new video also if you
want to watch something else right now
stuff from the archive over there on the
right and as always thank you for
watching